Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to reading your comments.
"Hey Mark, who was your first subscriber, mine is my cousin.
One more thing have fun on the tour in the Hoosier state."
Well that just goes to show how long it's been since the last reading your comments didn't mean do that
but the tour got in the way!
My first subscriber was actually my friend Michelle
Who did it more like a show of faith as a friend then firm belief that I would go on to
Accomplish things in YouTube but it still meant a lot to me
and along with that came some family members, some other friends
But the first one was definitely my friend Michelle, and I I owe a lot to that first show of faith
And then eventually my videos got kind of posted on Reddit and elsewhere
And then I got a lot more attention from that and then I started building from there,
But you know that was the first subscriber, and
You know it's really meaningful just to get that that one subscriber you may not even know who they are but,
You know that one.
It's the start of something special so it's kind of cool
"Who comes up with the titles for your videos?"
I do???
*sudden intense music* OR MAYBE THE ILLUMINATI DOES???
I don't know what kind of mad genius can possibly come up with such
illustrious and amazing titles
Such as this, and WHOA, and wow that's a good one
Coming up with the title is hard
You can't go to clickbaity unless you really want to or you can't go to boring and generic
So you kind of have to find this weird middle ground and oftentimes a title will be something that makes me laugh
but has nothing to do with the video, so
It's a fine line to walk, and there's no science to it.
"Have you ever been blackmailed at any time of your life? And if yes, how did you deal with it? Serious question."
Well serious answer, no I've never been blackmailed
I don't think being blackmailed is that common of a thing or maybe it is if you guys out there have been
Blackmailed in your life write down in the comments below because I don't know it seems like such a cloak-And-dagger
Style thing you get like a brick with a letter attached to a crash through your window
And you have to unravel it and its cut magazine papers
And they've got a tape of you banging a coconut or something and you just have to be like
"Oh, God! I don't want that video of me fucking that coconut to get out! Oh well!"
No, tha-that wasn't an example by the way that's never happened to me.
*laughing nervously* I've never- I've never banged a coconut before.
"Mark, what's the highest you can scream? I'm genuinely curious..."
Well the best thing for you to do on the first video would you record in the day
without any warm-up is scream as high as you can
Here we go!
*Marks screaming gradually becomes higher and is voice cracks*
Okay, that's about it as I that's about as good as that's gonna get
Sure all my neighbors are going to be very pissed
And every Dog in a ten-Mile radius is now dead
Chica no!
It was a joke that was just for goofs
Chica is alive and well!
Look at this bub!  Who is a bub?  Who's a bub?  Oh, it's the bubbiest bub!
She's so confused
"Try not to cry challenge, please. I'm desperate"
I don't know why why does everyone want me to cry so badly?
Oh, man, all I need to do to cry is watch some of you guys'
thank you videos or congratulations videos or anything like that like
Nothing gets me tearing up faster than any of those so maybe I'll do some ah...
Maybe it'll be a reaction video to something like that, but I don't know if i want to!
"Are you a potato god?"
I might be a potato,
But I make no claims to being a God!
"But sir, you are amazing!"
I am aware, but as a potato you need to have standards.
"Mark are you actually voicing 5.0.5 on Villainous? I've heard this going around, but don't know if it's actually true.
It is 100% true!
I am the voice of 5.0.5 on Villainous.
If you don't know what that is it's this lovable character right here this adorable bear.
*Makes cartoon bear noise*
Which is basically just all the voicing done for 505 is in,
*More cartoon bear noises*
So yeah, if you want to check out villainous up a link through the description below.
It's a Mexican animation studio one of their first things going up on Cartoon Network
They did it as an experiment, and it really picked up a lot of traction really quickly
So I'm actually pretty proud to be a part of it
And I hope it goes on to do great things in the future and if they want me to keep doing 5.0.5
I'm more than happy to contribute my voice.
*More bear noises*
"What do you think of....BACON!?"
Okay, I've said this before. I'm actually eating a very specific diet called the Keto diet,
And it's not really all that complicated all it amounts to is eating a ton of fat
No carb and some protein so when it comes to bacon
Bacon has become the staple of my entire diet
I pretty much eat bacon for breakfast lunch and dinner.
SO YES!
I LOVE BACON!
*giggling*
This one just made-
"Scaaaaar, bruthur save meh!"
Mufasa I don't thi-
Moofasu, I don't think I can- those tiny arms I just I can't deal with it. I'm sorry
"What's your favorite year and why?"
Are you talking about any year from the beginning of recorded history to now?
I'm just gonna go of the years that I've been doing YouTube.
I think 2014,
Was probably my favorite year just because
Was when I first moved to La and it was this beginning of this engine of creation that I started doing
And I threw out a lot of really weird and interesting
Concepts there like the impossible let's play that was when Five Nights at Freddy's first came about
That's when I started doing the vlogs on the regular
That's when I started doing these weird unboxing videos that I can't want to bring back
It wasn't really unboxing videos, but it was just I would go and I would get bullshit toys
And then I would play with them while I was doing a vlog
And I tried a lot of different things like that, and I kind of liked the concept of them
So they've been evolving and bleeding into my videos ever since
And I hope to someday refine them down into something that I can actually call
A real video!
Eh, maybe.
"If I saw Mark and Chica at the park I would probably go pet Chica first."
Well, to be perfectly honest, I would do the same
But also you're implying that after you're done petting Chica, you're gonna start petting me as well
And I don't know if I'm okay with that
I usually like meeting fans in the street, but if you start petting me
I'm not- I don't think I'm okay with that.
Don't pet me if you pet me I'm gonna bite ya
I will literally take a chunk out of your hand, you come-
You pet me I bite you
"Hey Mark, Can you share a bartending story? I'm interested in becoming a bartender and curious as to some stories about bartending."
Okay, so for those of you don't know
I was a bartender for about a month a little less than a month if you count the actual days that I was
working pretty much not very much, and I wasn't very experienced
So here's my embarrassing bartending story about my first day on the job
I actually knew the drinks pretty well, and I knew all the house drinks very well
But it was my first drink that I had ever served, and I froze up because the guy
Asked for a vodka cranberry, and that's not a complicated order
That's about as basic as an order can get in any aspect in any scenario a vodka cranberry
It's a highball glass, ice, vodka, cranberry juice. That's it.
But I panicked because I'd been studying up all these complicated drinks of various names
I had a whole book that I was like memorizing to the tee
I memorized every single of our 20 house drinks to the letter
And I practiced them all but when it came to my first order being a vodka cranberry
I completely froze up. I look this guy in the eye, I'm like
"You- you...You want that." I grabbed a shaker.
I filled it with ice, I just filled the fucking shaker with ice.
I took vodka and I just dumped that shit in, like I was totally playing it.
I was like looking to my fellow bartender for help
I was like "I don't- I don't know I- that's enough I guess"
And then I grabbed the cranberry juice I was like "I'm pretty sure this is how this goes but I think I'm doing
something wrong." the guy the bar is looking at me like "Are you-are you okay, man?
I can order something else. Could you get me a beer?"
and I'm like "No, I got this, I got it!" Put the Lid on
Shook it up real good like for way too long
I was just shaking and shaking and shaking someone photoshop a dick into my hand here-
I was just shaking up, and then I just it was obviously way too much, so I had a highball glass out there
I took that off. I took like a beer mug
And then I just poured the whole fucking thing into a beer mug it gave it to him, and he looked at me
You know normally if you over serve someone it's like
They're grateful this guy was so confused and my only saving grace
Is that this event only happened between this guy and myself
Nothing, no one else seemed to notice it
No one noticed it as soon as he paid he literally grabbed the mug and walked away.
And this is not a bar where you can take the drinks with you. He just fucking walked away and
I just let him go! I was like "All right you earned that.
I will pay,
whatever it cost to not deal with you."
"Markimoo I was wondering about how you overcame any self doubts about pursuing your YouTube career? If you do see or read this know
ihat you bring me so much joy every day when I click the play button. I'm never disappointed when watching a Markiplier video Thank you."
Well thank you very much
That's high praise to give me, and I'm pretty sure there's been some disappointing videos in the past
But when it comes to your question about how I overcame any self doubts about pursuing a YouTube career
It's a bit of a... it's a bit of a 'chicken before the egg' kind of question to ask yourself
because you can't have any self doubts if you haven't already imposed a limit on yourself and
The thing about a YouTube "career" is that when I was pursuing it it was not going to be my "career"
It's definitely not on the table,
and you should never approach it as that.
You shouldn't go into YouTube being like,
"This is the only thing I'm gonna do in my life and if I fail I am going to die."
Because that is going to cripple you and that cripples everybody that goes into something with that kind of energy
When you go into it, it's not that you don't have limitations
It's that if you impose caps on your skill
You don't realize the potential you have to learn and so when I went into it there was of course better YouTubers
than I was out at the time, there were people with millions of subscribers there were people, with all sorts of levels of success
But when I end- when I went into it,
I realized that I had so much to learn. And instead of allowing that to be a daunting fact
I just took that into myself and I realized
I have every day to try to learn a new thing
I have every day to try to learn more about this craft and make it into something great without worrying about
making money or making it my career or making it the thing that I was going to do all my life because
YouTube in and of itself is only a means by which to create.
And creation, is the thing that is fulfilling your life.
It doesn't define it it fulfills your life the ability to channel your creativity into something tangible like a video
But also that translates to anything else that you would create
So it, when it comes to overcoming self doubts there are no self doubts because I don't know what I can do
I will only know what I can't do
When I push myself through what I can
So I didn't have any doubts. I had none and it was because there were no doubts to have.
"The tour is over where da pole dancing vid?"
Well it would be there, but the person that I wanted to do it with hasn't gotten back to me yet.
So I may just have to buy my own pole and then figure that shit out on my own.
So we will see about that.
"MARK GO RUN INTO A TREE!!!!"
OK!